they are now officially moving on to gay
marriage we
said as we approached and learned about
and then got beyond the supreme court
decision overturning roe v wade that
they are not ending with overturning roe
v wade and why would they you don't get
your biggest win and then say now we
retire we don't want anything else
clarence thomas in his opinion and
others have said we've got to go on to
gay marriage we've got to go on to
gay adoption let's ban abortion outright
all of these different things and ted
cruz is now moving on and he is one of
many who are now focusing on this ted
cruz on his podcast is now saying
the issue of gay marriage
should also be left to states now what
does that mean
that means
states should be able to ban gay
marriage that's what you that's what you
mean when you say it should be decided
by the states listen to ted cruz
so berger fell
like roe versus wade ignored two
centuries of our nation's history
marriage was always an issue
that was left to the states you know
burger fell the court said no we know
better than you guys do and now every
state must
uh
must sanction and permit gay marriage
um i think that decision was clearly
wrong when it was decided
um
it was the court overreaching
imagine that applied to interracial
marriage listen
it's not that i'm against interracial
marriage it's that the supreme court
cannot decide that for the states states
must be allowed to determine do they
want to allow interracial marriages or
not that's the right way to do it and if
you extrapolate out from this idea of
leave everything to the states black
folks might still be enslaved in some
states in the south i mean maybe not
today but certainly into the early 1900s
that's for damn sure
civil rights and liberties are not
states rights issues they are guaranteed
by the constitution you don't put rights
up to a vote
at this point most americans recognize
that when you tell
one person
that they are able to get married and
someone else that they can't marry the
person that they love
you are deprying you you you are
depriving them of something that most
americans now recognize is a right you
just you can marry the person that you
love we're not talking about marrying
horses we're not talking about marrying
vehicles we're talking about two people
entering into a contract that they want
to enter into you just don't put that up
to a vote and if you said to them by the
way
well let states regulate guns however
they want
they would say no no no no no we need
the supreme court to tell states you
can't do that because of the second
amendment and in fact the supreme court
recently did do that with a case that
got to the supreme court related to gun
so this is obviously their next target
they're not hiding it they're being
clear they won't stop here and they're
going to keep going and this is as as
demoralizing as it has been to see what
happened with roe v wade
if we now say we're bailing out on the
political system
it will go to the next thing it will go
to gay marriage or whatever else because
they're they're uh inspired they're
activated they're fired up now
uh so it puts 2022 really in focus as i
would argue the most important midterm
election i've covered during the time
i've been doing the show if you disagree
with me let me know let me put it a
different way
has there been a more important midterm
election
i would even say
since 1994 when gingrich and that wacky
republican coalition took power tell me
i want to know has there been a more
important midterm than the one that is
forthcoming